With these tips
you can become instant creditor
and re-find your connection to God.
Number 1,
let all your doubts about God finally fall.
Most people then always arrive with Bock,
Have God forgiven me for all my sins?
You don't even know what sins I have committed?
Yes, he can,
but he died for us on the cross.
So no matter what you've done,
God can forgive you everything.
The most important thing is,
that you honestly,
honestly ask for forgiveness
and confess all these things to him.
The 2nd point is to be in any case.
With a baptism
in my opinion you can never do anything wrong
and that is the 1st right step,
to practically have God closer to you.
Tip number 3 is,
bury your old life before Jesus.
later you will believe it,
but once your sins are forgiven,
your old life doesn't count anymore.
So no matter what you've done in your previous life,
it doesn't matter.
It is important that you separate from it visually.
That is,
that you gradually remove practically all the things.
You will notice very quickly,
many things will be really easy for you,
such as how to cancel toxic friends,
thate you from God or something,
but then for example things like music
or dress revealingly.
so that I Struggle yes to this day still.
Number 4 is Down Rush.
Is very very important that you live for God,
but live.
Not for God,
because that's what User 96 somehow says,
that you are not a real Christian,
because you have so and so to live.
If you want 1 Part 2,
be sure to follow me,
Like the video!